we are counting down the most whatever
videos of 2016 from the youtube channel
today let's look at the most disliked
videos from youtube and before we do
that let me remind you know there's
funny thing where the trolls think that
by showing up in disliking our videos
they're really damaging what we're doing
and saying something really bad about
our channel the trolls don't seem to
realize that any comment and even a
dislike all count towards the YouTube
engagement al algorithm and it's funny
Pat when they come through and say I'm i
hate this channel I'm gonna hurt you by
disliking you and leaving a mean comment
you're actually helping us yeah maybe
you shouldn't say that but these people
can't control themselves anyway they
can't know I know the trolls can control
themselves I've have no fear about
saying that all right number five the
fifth most disliked video of 2016 math
increasingly suggests election fraud
against Hillary Clinton be fifth most
disliked video what is still should
still image of me there of 2016 the
fourth most disliked video of 2016 a
hatred mailed episode talk called
patriot mail admit that black people are
dangerous the fourth most disliked video
of 2016 next the third most disliked
video of 2016 not only one of our most
popular videos not only one of our most
liked videos but our third most disliked
video the scathing critique of Reza a
salon called Reza a salon cannot be
trusted from January of 2016 issue
edited and researched by uh intern in
segment producer Noah Ferguson the
second most disliked video of 2016 on
the david packard show youtube channel
trump forgets cameras exists as black
people are uneducated poor and jobless a
lot of people really really really did
not like that video and lastly the
number one most disliked video of 2016
on the youtube channel pat show it to us
it is embarrassing trump audio exposes
him as totally clueless not only the
most commented video of 2016 but the
most disliked video of 2016 and disliked
in great part
because Rush Limbaugh mentioned that
video made fun of me in it and clearly
directed a lot of traffic to it so it's
been quite a year in dislikes hasn't it
Pat yeah and he wouldn't even reference
your name I remember too he didn't but
uh we knew we knew what he was referring
to and indeed it drove a lot of traffic
to it wow wow make sure to subscribe to
our YouTube channel we are hoping to
have an even bigger 2017 than the 2016
we had which was our record year and
even bigger than the 2015 we had which
was then a record year and even bigger
than the 2014 we had and so on and so
forth all the way back to 2009 subscribe
and remember we are raising money at
david pakman.com slash donate if you
like the show if you've enjoyed watching
us during 2016 think about donating a
little something